god dude I've have you have you ever
been on a corporate Richard I've never
been on one of those yep you have oh
yeah oh yeah
no the only ones ever exactly what you
would think it would be dude we went to
oh my god this is crazy I'm just I
haven't thought about this in years
repressed memory time let's go that's
wild we went to this place in Northern
California it was it was oh my god you
know what it was it was a [ __ ]
scavenger hunt we did one of these Road
Trip scavenger hunts where the last stop
was Half Moon Bay and we did stop in
Santa Cruz and we had to stop and yet we
had to stop in Marin County I believe
and everything so it was like north and
then we went all the way south and we
ended up in Half Moon Bay and then we
went to some [ __ ] like random hotel
in the middle of nowhere and really did
like exercises with people like this guy
would come in we had to do like startup
idea exercises and stuff like that and
like working with a small team come up
with some like it's like something
something you do in business school you
know oh but with your coworkers I'm just
thinking about like a 6 7 hour car ride
with like a back-end developer a client
services person and then like some other
person like an HR person and you're just
like well we can't we literally can't
talk about anything yeah we have nothing
in common with each other do just a size
work he doesn't have to do yeah but it's
like you're in like a Matt imagine
they're like different enough
departments or like someone like I say a
person because meaning like you can't
even make inappropriate [ __ ] like you
just got to sit there and do customer
service for eight hours yeah that is a
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god I quit I
quit I get a [ __ ] uber and go home it
really was something else like we were
in one of these like old wooden hotels
in the middle of the forest yeah so
there's no escape you're just there
you're isolated with your coworkers
I felt like I was in a movie or
something yeah like I was in Silicon
Valley that TV show yeah the only like
corporate retreat type thing I did is I
got sent to a [ __ ] dev conference for
JavaScript mm-hm in San Francisco and it
was dumb as hell because I was there for
like basically one and a half was it one
and a half days I I don't know it was
like it was so short of a time that I
didn't bring I brought I brought like
just like two pairs of underwear and
like another shirt and like some socks
and then I ended up just having all that
in my back but I remember the day I
landed the hotel wouldn't let me in for
like until the evening like you know
you're supposed to get 3 o'clock
check-in but they were like oh yeah
sorry your rooms not gonna be ready till
10:00 so I was just walking around San
Francisco burning up the Tenderloin yeah
the Tenderloin no I was I was like right
there and it was hot is [ __ ] I
thought was gonna be cold so I was
wearing like long sleeves with with like
a jacket and I was with a beanie and I'm
stripping all these layers but I'm just
[ __ ] dying just the computer and all
the [ __ ] in my backpack has made it
worse and I had like one of these goofy
like I don't I gave up on life backpacks
so they keep in my laptop
weirdly would transfer through to the
back so I just had sweaty back like
exponential you've never felt more like
a developer than and now helmet no it
felt so terrible sweaty back looking for
a coffee bean that you can work at it
did exactly that I'm sitting I'm like I
found some Starbucks and I'm working on
whatever dumb [ __ ] side project that
you know that you're always working on
as a dev and I'm like just writing this
code with hot-ass back with all my
underwear falling out of my backpack I'm
like this is [ __ ] what it how did I end
up here you know the the piss room in
Bergheim that was actually inspired by
the Tenderloin because your chances of
getting pissed on just walking down the
street pretty [ __ ] high oh yeah
and in SF mega you can't walk around
downtown San Francisco with an open
mouth
you gotta be very careful they might get
coughed into peed into you know comment
ooh yeah the the Matt the man comment is
a blessing for downtown San Francisco ya
need exactly you need that needed yeah
that's so funny man I went to WWDC twice
with my coworkers yeah but that I I
lived in Palo Alto so that was just take
the train up but then us all day in the
city and that actually is in the
Tenderloin or somewhere around there
that it's an sorry go ahead
no I want to say that it doesn't seem
like it'd be that horrible it no it was
like I mean I was you know really into
programming and the iOS SDK and all the
new [ __ ] they were coming out with I was
like genuinely very very interested in
that and it all sort of helped us a lot
like we would go to these conferences
that they had talking about the new you
know api's and stuff and we would we
would meet with an engineer that worked
on it that works for Apple we would meet
with him on the spot and talk about how
we can implement this into our app so we
would have the most cutting-edge [ __ ] it
was actually really like stimulating the
WWDC that I went to is just programmer
memory our yeah this is just random
memory access bars walking bars right
there one from my l1 cache I remember
the one that I went to was when they
first came out with whatever version of
iOS first had that the animations in
iMessage where everything like bubbles
and that was the hottest conference to
go to or a room or prison presentation
whatever the [ __ ] was the animation guy
that wrote that he did he did he
presented the the API and how you can
implement it into your own app and I
remember like it was line out the
[ __ ] door dude like a thousand people
in this giant auditorium room learning
about this bubble I
animation that this guy had wrote
because it was so like the hottest [ __ ]
it still does that right um when you go
to have messages yeah when you scroll up
and down and the message is coming like
bounce off of each other you know we sat
down right after that and tried to tried
to implement it couldn't figure it out
the letdown about the conference I went
to I realize on the whole the whole
thing was a scam when I went to some
guys talk about like some framework
called ember I don't about it yeah yeah
and I was like I'm like all right it's
30 minutes let's go check it out I pop
in there this [ __ ] just
promoting his startup the whole time I'm
like oh you you paid a bit [ __ ] did
everyone who's actually smart here I've
never been so upset and I like my boss
is like when I got back she's like you
need to write something about what you
learned that I can give to you know the
CTO and I was like dude you're like
you're like I'm writing I'm running an
application letter actually but yeah
that's what I'm gonna do you just pay
for me to go get hired by another
company anybody in there I should have
just like just dude you just pay to go
to one of those and you just do a set so
I built an application that tracks time
which is perfect for a stand-up comedian
what's everyone I am and I will be
running my own light tonight Oh a you
want to talk about a line out the door
they had a Facebook Rev he was like one
of the cord from the core team of the
guys who made react oh man that guy was
getting a Hello programmer [ __ ] yeah
what year was this 2014 yeah yeah okay
so this is when it first started
everyone thought it was gonna be the
next [ __ ] which it is so many people use
react now yeah reacts huge but he oh man
program programmer dudes lined to the
[ __ ] back yeah
standing room only this guy was the
Jesus of the conference dude he got up
there like ah this is [ __ ] dan
Danielson from Facebook and he's here to
talk about react
[ __ ] dudes throwing bras yeah
programmers pointing out their [ __ ]
my boobs
relax dude it was wild he'd show like a
feature of react in the whole room ago
they start clapping start clapping your
rock star dude anyone can be a rock star
in their own regard they truly can man
that's a life lesson right there
I did not think program programming
could elicit that kind of response I was
blown away oh yeah he probably got laid
yeah you got laid thick with hella
questions but I do went out to a bar
afterward so many [ __ ] [ __ ] be
like so I'm working on my app right now
so let me I have a question about the
tableview
[Laughter]
tech let's end this episode play my chip
song oh yeah I finished this with the
chat yesterday
oh [ __ ] hold on I have to UM alright
let's see if this works you can just
drop it in Chrome I'm pretty sure
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
ha
I got the chip guys go get your chips
[Music]
wait wait the best parts coming out hold
on
[Music]
hi Eric
[Music]
[Laughter]
the dobre brothers are like yes
[ __ ] me daddy call 1-800 Big Brother to
get your chip for free 10 right now for
a limited time offer you can also get
[Music]
[Music]
there it is maybe the chip
you